it's great to have back on the program
today Michael Cohen former personal
attorney to Donald Trump also host of
the Maya culpa podcast and author of The
forthcoming book Revenge how Donald
Trump weaponized the U.S Department of
Justice against his critics it's out on
October 11th and you can pre-order it
already on Amazon Michael great having
you on I appreciate it good to see you
David so I mean I don't really by the
way just to let you know you can
actually pre-order a signed copy a
limited edition signed copy if you go to
Revenge hyphenthebook.com Revenge hyphen
the book.com for signed copies beautiful
um there are at least four
investigations right now into the former
president uh you've got the New York
Finance investigation the Mar-A-Lago
document Scandal you've got January 6th
and then you have the Georgia election
results
given your knowledge of Donald Trump is
he genuinely rattled by this stuff or
does he think he's just sort of in you
know invulnerable
well this
unfortunately I can't give you the
answer to that one because Donald is a
narcissistic sociopath so how he
expresses himself as it relates to any
one specific issue
it's very hard to get into his head from
his body language I can tell you that
this mod that this Mar-A-Lago raid
really got to him
um
but so did the Tisch James lawsuit that
is now confronting him because that
attacks his you know his ego it attacks
what basically he's lived for his whole
life which is to be able to impress upon
others how rich he is and this 220 page
indictment
it negates all of that by simply showing
that he's really nothing more than just
a petty con man
you explain during your testimony under
oath years ago I don't even remember now
exactly when it was it's all kind of
been a blur but you explained this
strategy
of claiming that an asset is worth more
if you want to use it as collateral for
a loan but claiming that the very same
asset is worth less if you're trying to
reduce your property taxes that that you
owe how explicit was that strategy when
you were Trump's personal attorney was
it openly discussed
so
as I explained and I the I think you're
referring to the 2018 testimony before
the house oversight committee was the
late great Elijah Cummings God Rest his
soul
um every year
Alan weisselberg and I would be called
into Donald's office
at which point Didn't
do the personal financial statement of
the year before how much more money he
believes that he is worth
and how he wants the personal financial
statement to reflect that now
one of the things was
the reason why he was doing it and the
initial reason
was for Forbes Magazine he is obsessed
with being on that Forbes 400 list but
he didn't want to just be on the list he
of course wanted to be as high on the
list as he possibly could
and so for example in 2012 like he would
say I you know I'm not worth uh as in
2011 four billion dollars I'm actually
worth six and a half and then the year
after he would say I'm worth eight No in
fact I'm worth nine and then it would go
on and on like this and these are random
numbers that Donald would just create in
his head simply because
he would say the real estate market is
good this year meaning that my assets
are worth more well again one of the
things that he testified to in the Tim
O'Brien case was that appraisals to him
don't really mean anything it's all what
he believes the value of the price to be
it's selective pricing so to speak
and so what's interesting about that is
if he is just sort of deluded about what
these properties that were are worth
it's less overtly criminal in a sense
right because he's not saying I don't
believe that this is the value he's
deluded into thinking that it is
I don't think so what happens is he may
be he may be deluded into the total net
worth but as we would sit there for
example the famous case of his Triplex
apartment I don't care how deluded you
are in your mind you know that your
house in this case the triplex apartment
is not 33 000 square feet how do you
know such a crazy thing because you live
there not only in his case does he live
there he actually built it so imagine
you're building a house in whatever city
state you know that you live in
and somebody comes over and they said oh
um did you just build a house yeah I
just built it and then you tell me it's
33 000 square feet when in fact it's 10
800 and change clearly it's a lie then
on top of that not only as the developer
not only as the owner not only as the
person whose name is on the building you
know that no property
has ever traded not just in that
building but anywhere in New York City
for that price per square foot coming up
with what a
370 million dollar valuation on his
apartment
that's not delusional right that's a
liar that's fair that's fair
um one of the things thank you for
saying that David one of the things that
uh that Donald Trump mentioned after the
pictures uh were released from the
search warrant that was served at
Mar-A-Lago was you know the pictures
make it look like my office is a mess
and my office is not really a mess
um however there are older pictures of
Trump's office where there are you know
books uh and and papers stacked all over
the place and and it does sort of seem
like a mess was it typical that the
offices were a mess
No in fact his office was extremely
um
it was extremely clean and organized
um there were times that his desk would
have papers cluttered on it but
remember something I'm talking about
Trump Tower on the 26th floor what he
would do is he would have stacks of
magazines and papers in the front of the
desk whereby of course your chair if you
were in a meeting with him would be that
and those magazines would have covers of
him on it or articles of him and if you
were let's say David Pacman comes into
Donald Trump for whatever the reason
might be you could sometimes end up
leaving with a little bag full of
magazines and newspaper clippings and
you know a little piece of a silver or a
gold Trump chocolate bar things like
that I mean you walk out there you think
that this was some sort of a carnival
that people are handing things or a job
fair that's really what it would look
like but for the most part his desk was
rather organized now
when the FBI raided Mar-A-Lago what
you're looking at is the office which is
above the um catering hall
and all of these documents are on the
floor I believe that they were placed on
the floor by the FBI so that they could
so that they could um photograph it when
the FBI raided my hotel room it was
funny my wife had several thousand
dollars
um that she had collected
for you know um from the real real on
items that she had sold and she would do
it so she wouldn't have to tell me to
buy it and it was in the safe with her
money and in fact on the envelope it
said real real money so she would know
what she was getting they fanned it out
it was something like
six thousand dollars or something like
that they fanned it out like they just
raided and found Escobar's billions and
you know they this is this is what they
do but I do have to say that when they
came in they were professional they were
respectful they did not destroy the
place they they were they did their job
and they did it the right way and I
suspect that they did the same thing at
Mar-A-Lago now why'd they lay it out on
the floor again maybe it was just so
that they could take the picture but we
have to thank them for taking those
pictures and the reason I say that is we
see that there are dozens of top secret
file folders and now we know that many
of those file folders were empty right
now rest assured he wasn't taking those
folders so that he could make menus out
of them for Mar-A-Lago you know for
their lunches and dinners there must
have been documents in there and we know
some of those documents were really top
secret
Eyes Only on the person who wrote it
nuclear secrets about whether it's our
adversary and our Ally so we have to
really thank them for doing their job
professionally I'm sure it wasn't easy
to go in and raid the home of the former
president of the United States but they
they did what they needed to do without
a doubt without a doubt speaking of
representation in in that matter and the
others what do you make of the lawyers
that show up on TV as Trump's lawyer
like Alina Haba and Christina Bob for
example this is a very different Cadre
of lawyers than the folks that were
photographed showing up in court the
other day is it just that Trump says hey
I like the way that these women look
let's hire them and make them more like
a PR type people that talk for me on TV
but they're not actually representing me
before a court is is it as simple as
that well that's not true by the way so
the answer is the visuals for him are
extremely important and he believes that
it also gives him a sense of strength
masculinity he's a very complex
individual
Alina how about does go to court oh she
does she's representing Donald in a
lawsuit that I currently have against
the United States government against the
Department of Justice Donald Trump Bill
Barr for the unconstitutional remand of
me back to Otisville because I refuse to
waive my first amendment constitutional
rights so maybe what she met Michael
just to clarify is she was not
representing him in court in the
particular matter she was being
interviewed about maybe that's what she
meant that's that's correct she just
makes she just makes her statements
um I find her to be
as unqualified in court as she is on
television oh and the same thing goes
with Bob who I think is somewhat
brighter than Alina in the fact that she
doesn't always open up her mouth and say
what Donald wants her to say
um that's a real problem however what
Bob did
um is she signed a document
that the government of course is in
possession of that claims that Donald is
not in possession and that she has must
have made some sort of a thorough check
but based upon the statements of her
client she signed an affidavit that no
additional documents exist in the
possession of trump or at Mar-A-Lago and
that's clearly a lie so is she in
trouble for it she certainly could be I
mean it's um it's a perjury charge but
look at what Donald does it's who's
going to be the next fool who's gonna be
the next Michael Cohen fool to fall on
the sword for this orange crested
Mandarin Mussolini who doesn't care
about anyone and so you begin to see
these various lawyers especially the
competent ones walk away and they walk
away for two reasons because Trump's
strategy only benefits Trump even if it
hurts the lawyer and worse than that he
doesn't tell them the truth let me make
a third one he also it doesn't pay yeah
other than this recent one
um
who took the money up front and good for
him yes Save America pack of reportedly
paid something like 3.8 million to a
West Palm Beach firm in the last couple
of months so it seems like now lawyers
are demanding money up front which seems
very very smart Michael if you had to
handicap all of the different
investigations going on right now which
is the most likely to actually lead to
charges
well we already know that the Tisch
James case is the one that is the most
active and the most upfront
next up
this is like a ball game right next up
is um the District Attorney's case uh
here in New York whereby Allen
weiselberg has already pled guilty right
to various criminal charges but they
have intelligently held off in the
sentencing of his case
post his testimony against the Trump
organization now let me just reiterate
for your listeners that the Tish James
case is a civil case this is the case
that will ultimately
wipe him out financially and again in
the 220 plus page document one of the
things that Tish James puts in there is
that her Baseline number
was 250 million and I want to draw
people's attention to the word Baseline
that is not the that is not the cap that
is the Baseline knowing the documents
that they used and knowing the case as
well as I do I suspect the number will
be closer to 750 million to a billion
that's what I think she will ultimately
go after now
the district attorney the case that was
originally brought by Cyrus Vance Jr now
inherited by Alvin Brigg that's a
criminal matter and that criminal matter
is
as weitzelberg would like you to believe
is against the Trump organization
how do you separate Donald Trump out
from the Trump organization his
eponymous company you cannot
let me just say one last thing that Tish
James has already referred certain parts
of that
220 page document
on tax evasion to the IRS and to the doj
so everything is beginning
to come full circle I mean I know that
we always say that the wheels of Justice
unless you Michael Cohen that's a
48-hour ordeal yeah that was quick turn
slowly
But ultimately it does come full circle
in the book you write about I mean as
the as the the full title of the book
suggests the use of the Department of
Justice essentially as a as a tool as an
intimidation tool and as a weapon
against those who criticized Donald
Trump
how much further did he want the doj to
go and the doj was unwilling to do it
because he made way more requests than
they actually uh agreed to didn't they
yes they did now in my specific case
Jeffrey Berman just came out with a book
and again I have no regard for him or
his book so I want to be clear about
that
I think Jeffrey Berman
his actions are either one of two things
unethical or illegal
Donald Trump threw Bill Barr
placed pressure on the southern district
of New York the Department of Justice to
expunge his name from anything related
to the actions the claims that were
brought against me initially that I
ultimately pled guilty to and my book
Revenge right how Donald Trump
weaponized the United States Department
of Justice against his critics it really
takes a deep dive into everything and
Jeffrey Berman is of course named in my
book as well but what it does
What Jeffrey Berman's book does is it
validates everything that I say in my
book it shows that Donald Trump's goal
was to use the Department of Justice as
his own private Law Firm his own private
hit squad to go against people that he
didn't like myself people like James
Comey uh and you know uh and others
the uh book is an extraordinary expose
of more as you say the inner workings of
how all this was done the book is out on
October 11th but it is available for
pre-order now as well as signed
pre-order we've been speaking with
Michael Cohen the book's author and
again the book is Revenge how Donald
Trump weaponized the U.S Department of
Justice against his critics Michael
always great having you on and best of
luck with the book release thanks David
and I will speak to you soon